welcome back to CBS mornings we have an
update on a story we've been following
here for months about people who say
they were falsely arrested after hurts
accused them of stealing cars they
rented some 230 people have filed claims
against the rental car company in a
federal bankruptcy court we recently
told you about a man who was held in a
Florida jail over what he says was a
false Hearst police report only on CBS
Morning he talks on camera with our
consumer investigative correspondent
Anna Warner about the experience he
calls horrific
Charles Doucette says he's still living
the day he was arrested it is the
scariest situation you will ever be in
along with the two weeks he spent Behind
Bars after hurts accused him of stealing
a car he had rented I was scared for
my life at some points in time Doucette
had been enjoying a pandemic delayed
cruise to the Caribbean with his
girlfriend but when the ship docked in
Florida last month Customs officers
acting on hertz's theft report arrested
him cuffed him and marched him off to
jail it's something I can't get out of
my mind his nightmare began with what
this traveling Pharmacy and health care
consultant says was a routine rental one
of many he's had over the past several
years as a consistent Hertz customer
with top-tier President Circle status I
recommended Hertz to friends family
clients he really liked him a lot it
sounds like I did in November 2020
Doucette says he had once again rented a
car from Hertz for his business this
time in Salt Lake City extending the
rental several times through March but
in early March Hertz filed a police
report accusing him of stealing the car
police stopped him in Arizona and towed
the car he says he assumed it was a
mistake especially since that same day
doucet's bank statement shows Hertz
charged his credit card nearly four
thousand dollars payment for the rental
in full he says he thought it was
resolved but an Arizona Court later
issued a warrant which led to his arrest
on that cruise ship in Florida I can
still see myself almost from like a
third party view coming down the gangway
of the boat in handcuffs what does that
moment feel like to you when you think
about that it's embarrassing it's it's
demeaning until you live that moment you
really can't put it into words
um
it's something I will live with for the
rest of my life I will never forget it
he spent two weeks in a Florida jail
then was flown in handcuffs to Arizona
where the warrant had been issued and
released the same day it's very surreal
we met up with him in Las Vegas where he
was waiting to catch a flight home to
New Hampshire as we sit here today you
still have charges pending against you
yes felony charges yes nothing has
changed
and there's more since our first story
on doucette's case ran February 15th
Hertz has brought up new claims now
accusing Doucet for the first time of
not paying nearly three thousand dollars
for a prior rental in June 2020 and
having his rental privileges suspended
then getting around the suspension while
renting the car in Salt Lake City six
months later by changing the state on
his driver's license from New Hampshire
to Alabama
their accusations are absurd plainly put
absurd and blatantly false have you ever
had a rental that you didn't pay for no
have you ever had anybody from here to
say to you we've suspended your rental
privileges not once in fact that June
2020 rental Hertz claims he failed to
pay for Doucet provided these documents
showing he disputed a nearly three
thousand dollar charge with his bank he
says because of overcharges and the bank
resolved it by refunding his money and
as to submitting a fake Alabama a
driver's license
absolutely false I've never even been to
Alabama so no
his attorney Francis Alexander malafi
once Hertz was aware this was a mistake
they did nothing to correct the false
information and instead they're trying
to victimize the victim and it should be
the last thing that they're doing I'm
innocent I shouldn't have to explain why
my mug shot is Nationwide my mug shot
should not even be out there and if it
wasn't for hearts it wouldn't be
well Hertz denies it did anything wrong
here the company says it made multiple
attempts to contact Doucette including
sending a certified letter demanding
Return of the car Doucette says he never
got any of those notifications Hertz
maintains these situations are very rare
meanwhile Doucet still has to appear in
court later this month on those theft
charges
such a bizarre story Anna thank you so
much for staying on top of it and you
know we don't know how rare it is
because Hertz has been fighting in court
to keep the numbers of false arrests
Secrets right and if you are one of the
230 people who are filing claims against
Hertz or you're Mr Doucet who spent two
weeks in jail you don't care about the
statistics right you only care about
making it right yeah and the pain you
went through that's right no question